adversaire malheureux de lionel jospin
et henri emmanuelli affirme lui qu'il ne
sera pas un mauvais perdant et qu'il
jouera le jeu cécile berne ici henri
emmanuelli est en terrain conquis
entourée de béton fidèles qui ont voté à
la quasi unanimité pour celui qu'ils
appellent souvent leurs amis un bruit
malvy 1487 voix soit 91,28 ou enfin
devant un plébiscite dans le département
mais ces applaudissements ont un goût
amer ce matin henri emmanuelli le sait
déjà
au niveau national c'est lionel jospin
qui l'emportent
quand on perd ça fait jamais plaisir
mais enfin quand on est compétiteur
quelque part il faut aussi des sportifs
quoi faut pas être mauvais perdant donc
si je suis perdant je ne serai pas
mauvais perdant contrairement à la
caricature a fait de moi donc il y aura
pas de guerre fratricide comme ça a été
proclamé depuis quinze jours et ça se
passera le plus normalement du monde
malgré la déception l'ambiance était à
la peine aujourd'hui dans les landes il
faudra quoi qu'il en soit soutenir le
candidat du parti socialiste
quant à henri emmanuelli il doit décider
si par ce vote les militants l'ont aussi
désavoué en tant que premier secrétaire